jilin province in china's northeast is
the latest epicenter of the country's
coronavirus outbreak with hundreds of
cases confirmed there in the past few
days mass testing is underway and a
makeshift hospital designed to
accommodate 1500 is now open
further south similar scenes in the city
of qingdao people that have been ordered
to take covert 19 tests by community
medical workers
we have set up six testing sites in our
community due to the tight schedule we
have to conduct testing overnight
cases of the omicron variant are surging
nationwide with thousands of infections
reported in recent days
it's the biggest outbreak here since the
pandemic began
more than 17 million people in the city
of shenzhen have been put under lockdown
for at least a week
people can only leave home to buy
necessities all public transport has
been suspended the forced closure of
businesses and factories in the tech hub
saw china's stock markets drop on monday
in shanghai parks schools and
universities have also been closed
authorities are doing all they can to
prevent large outbreaks in major cities
our team in beijing is among the
millions affected by china's strict
covert 19 controls because one omicron
case was found in our office building
last week we've all been told to
quarantine and work from home until
further notice
rapid antigen tests or horm testing kits
have been made available to the chinese
public for the first time
antigen tests cannot replace nucleic
acid tests but they can help identify
the possible source of infection in a
timely manner before nucleic acid tests
are conducted
experts abroad have criticized china's
zero tolerance strategy as unsustainable
but beijing has doubled down on its
approach saying it's kept deaths from
the virus to a minimum katrina u al
jazeera beijing